مليون و600 الف حاله تسمم غذائي يوميا
بسبب تناول اطعمه ملوثه اي ان المتوسط
السنوي للاصابات 600 مليون حاله رقم صادمه
مشاهدينا لفتاه اليها الامم المتحده في
اليوم العالمي لسلمه الاغذيه والذي حمل
شعار معايير الغذاء تنقذ الارواح في عالم
تكتظ فيه السوق بالاطعمه المعباه
والمعالجه فان قراءه ملصقات الطعام امر في
غايه الاهميه رموز واشكال لا نعطيها
اهتماما
خبراء التغذيه ينصحونك
بعزف بها نظرا الى المعلومات المهمه التي
يمكن الحصول عليها عن المنتج
طبعا لازم نعطي الملصق الغذائي
نحن عم نتسوق غذائيا لحتى حافظ على صحتنا
كتير سؤال حلو شو اكثر شيء اذا ما كان عنا
وقت كتير بالسوبر ماركت نقراه كرمال نتاكد
المنتج الغذائي اللي نحن عم نتسوق ولنا
ولعائلتنا ولاولادنا امن صحيا وامن غذائيا
بالبدايه بدنا نقول في عنا دائما عم نلاقي
حرف الاي على الملصق الغذائي هذا دليل على
وجود ماده ملونه او ماده حافظه حسب الرقم
يلي موجود ضمن
بجانب الحرف على المنتج الغذائي كل ما
كانت اقل عدد
المضافات الغذائيه والمواد الحافظه اللي
هي بتبتدا باي مثل اي 102 124 كلمه هدول
المنتجات كان المنتج اكثر الصحه واكثر
عافيه منروح لايضا كل ما كانت المواد
الموجوده ضمن المنتج اقل على سبيل المثال
اذا بدنا نشتري علبه بسكويت اذا كان قمح
بيض ماء السكر مواد نحن بنعرفها كمستهلك
هيك نحن معناتها هذا
يعني منتج جيد نوعا ما اما اذا لقينا
بقلبه مثلا غريبه اسماء ملصق فيها كلمه
شغلات غريبه على المستهلك نحاول نتجنب
هالمنتج لانه بيكون في نسبه كبيره من
المواد الحافظه وايضا الملح اللي له اسماء
مختلفه نحن بغينا عنا هناك من يقول بان
نسبه المواد الحافظه لا تؤثر لكن في بعض
الاسامي احنا ما نعرفها
فلوريد ما بعرف ايش
تراقين الاسامي ما انزل الله بها من سلطان
ما راح نعرف هي شنو كرمال هيك نحن بدنا
نقول
في ضوء المواد
الملونه والاغذيه الموجوده لكن كل ما
قللنا من استهلاكها بالمنتج الغذائي اللي
نحن عم نتسوق وعلى بيتنا كل ما حافظنا
اكثر على استدامه صحتنا وصحه عائلتنا
وعززنا من عافيتنا
[موسيقى]